e
it is uh 10:04 so it's ready to go uh we
will start as we
all always do with with the
pledge and this morning representative
Gallagher you are up to lead us in the
pledge thank you representative
Gallagher uh before we get going today
we have one sub uh representative
elberger welcome back again
and with that we'll ask the clerk to
call the
attendance thank you Mr chairman uh Vice
chairman in power present representative
Guthrie clerk is here representative
lales here representative Kell present
representative Kelly here representative
aood Pres representative Brown here
representative kahill here
representative stavis here
representative Tetro here uh
representative elberger here
representative Gilman here
representative major here representative
Gallagher here representative Hicks here
representative Holland here
representative priest here uh
representative Frack here and Mr
chairman
Pres
well good morning everybody uh we have
three bills that we will exec today uh
in talking with the minority leader on
the committee what we are going to do is
go through each bill we have
multiple um amendments on some of them
so we'll go we'll talk about each
bill and then I'm going to recess them
one at a time to the end and what will
we what we will do at that point is we
will take a caucus so we can all discuss
to make sure everybody's on the same
page or we know what we're doing um so
with that we will open up the exec
session on HB
1223 which it says amend amend the whole
thing creating local Ops for games of
chance so we'll open up the exec session
on
that and there is amendment number
1218 that I will introduce and put on
the floor and open it up for
discussion nobody has any discussions on
hb12 23 representative power thank you
Mr chairman um was someone going to
speak to this amendment and go through
what the amendment is doing
doing I assume so representative
majority looks like you have something I
was going to ask the same question Mr
chairman okay um I don't normally do
this in an exact session would you all
like to hear
from well one of the sponsors isn't here
but I think somebody can no nobody wants
to talk to
it okay
um do not take this as a precedent for
this
committee because it isn't a precedent
but I will if you would like to come up
and speak to it I will allow allow you
to I know you've been involved with just
more than just about anybody else so
please state your name and then of
course I very much appreciate the
opportunity to address the committee
during your executive session and
explain this amendment that we've put
together I uh worked our group of
citizens from Littleton worked
uh through me uh and also um in
consultation and we worked with Rick
Newman the lobbyist for the casino group
and um brought forward these changes and
I've sent an email last night to
describe a bit of that process and um I
apologize to those who are substitute
that you didn't get that directly from
me uh but I will capsule this uh we did
change the previous one we eliminated uh
two sections and we only have one
section now of the bill it used to be
the third section this is the local
option for games of chance the game of
chance employer license is the substrate
it's the holding uh license for all of
the games that are played in the casino
and so this is the spot to get um the
best decisions made and so in um it will
add a section 287d 30 to um local option
games of chance in that um anyone who is
the first section exempts those who are
basically renewing a license so if
they're already in place and they have
to get their renewal every two years or
three years depending upon how that
resolves in other venues um they do not
have to get this local option going this
is only for new uh casinos that are um
planned for community in a uh it talks
about these are basically drawn from the
statute that covers local option for
Kino it was almost directly um copied
from that so A Town would be petitioned
to put it on the ballot if it passes um
then the casino could go in that town in
a city there's a petition that goes in a
different way and still it goes on the
ballot a majority would allow the casino
to operate in that town um there's a
public hearing under see the wording of
the the uh referendum or the the
um how how it goes on the ballot in a
Roman two three if it's not approved it
can be later done at the as early as the
next
year
and let's see in
there are those who are exempt from this
who are not yet licensed and those um Mr
Newman referred to as in the pipeline
there are five applications in um
process in holding pattern over at the
Lottery Commission and those five
applications are exempt from this local
ordinance or this local um option thing
just as an aside that's not exactly what
Littleton wanted but nonetheless it will
be good for the whole state um any other
community that is approached by a casino
would have that opportunity to either
welcome them or um refuse entry in uh
Roman 4 it's how to remove that
permission and this applies to all
casinos even currently operating even
those in the pipeline that if after 7
years they haven't opened
or if after seven years there's seven
years of them being closed not in use
for any reason at all um then the town
can put forward a petition to resend or
um remove the permission for them to
operate in that town and that if passed
would have to cover a threshold of 60%
of the vote um an unincorporated place
has the same threshold but it goes
through the delegation could you hold up
one second um could you speak
specifically to just what has been
changed since the last one we don't need
a a a rehash of the main body of the
bill just what the amendment does thank
you Mr chairman um actually almost done
with that long winded thing um but um
what changed was um protecting the ones
in the pipeline what changed were the
number of years in is 7 years the other
one was three and 10 3 years to start or
to open 10 years of not being open at
all of of nonuse it they're both seven
now seven years not open seven years um
before opening in the Roman 4 I'm sorry
Roman 8 if they have voted the town has
voted not to have games of chance
commercially in their Community they
could on ordinance allow a certain
number of days that local um Charities
could run their own casino night as is
accustom sometimes now and that's
covered by another RSA 287
D4 they could do that okay thank
you
um you want to ask a question or I I
prefer
to if it's something you need to ask i'
prefer to leave that there and go to
exact okay thank you very
much somebody you're all set yeah just
turn off the mic please she's
representative
stavis we're just going to Talk Amongst
ourselves now turn off the mic
please so I have a number of questions
and um observations about the amendment
what's missing I believe and yes the did
come in very late so if I've missed it
my apologies but what's missing is any
mention of historical horse racing
correct and I think I can speak to that
okay I think we heard in testimony prior
that historical horse racing can only be
uh brought in
if this here the casino already exists
so I think they removed she's shaking
her head yes and Curtis is shaking his
head yes so I think they remove that
maybe to make it a little bit
simpler um should I continue go ahead uh
in lines 11 12 13 and 14 uh where it
sets the the limit of the recision of
permission in Lebanon the casino
operators had to go before the planning
board which
took more than six months just to go
through the planning board process
process I don't know how how long it
took before that to get ready to go
through the planning board process and
so I wonder if this number of um seven
years might conflict with planning board
processes in other municipalities where
things just tend to take a long time and
through no fault of the casino
operator's
own much as I may not
be in favor of casinos but that's beside
the point this may conflict with those
two things may conflict with one another
so I'm concerned about that I don't
believe they do I'll try to answer as
best I can and we can watch the shaking
heads or the whatever up there um the
way I read this it says that this is
that's only after the approval has been
granted uh the seven years so once the
approval is granted there's a
seven-year and I'm seeing
what approval approval from what
Authority uh the gaming I would say the
gaming commission or the I think it's
the
municipality the paragraph above talks
about license by the
lottery as of May 2021 so I'm assuming
that's once they go through the approval
um as de mentioned there's five existing
Casino applications right
now right none of these none of those
would be affected by this and I believe
those have would have to be approved
once those are
approved by the gaming commissions they
have seven years to basically begin
operation otherwise the municipality
would then have the ab ility to resend
am I reading that correctly I'm seeing a
head
shaken repres representative savs I
think it's just unclear okay in in the
amendment as it's presented to what what
approval this refers to is it
the Lottery Commission is it the plan
board is
it is it the
municipality that is empowered to say
yes or no by this bill I would say it
the one you're looking at it talks about
RSA 28 287d so I would assume that where
they talk about the approval process
representative
McDonald uh thank you Mr chairman how
many total licenses are they going to
allow in the state do you know is there
a set limit that I do not
know representative
yell thank you um so the the legislative
uh body uh the house is already passed a
moratorium on additional um
applications um so at this point
whatever the number is is the number and
this bill only talks about new numbers
which are going to be sometime in the
future since there's a currently a
moratorium and so um since the
moratorium is lasting for multiple years
there's no rush with this legislation to
to be Um this can be filed normally in
in uh due course and have its hearing
and be fully vetted um but by what I
believe to be the correct committee and
also I think they there is a lack of um
in this amendment as the previous
Amendment there is um a changing of the
ways that this that these establishments
can come about but there is no changing
of the means of the
um if a municipality decides that they
don't want a game of chance then I think
that that the discussion should be had
about what whether or not they should be
benefiting from the tax revenue of that
if they uh are um so opposed to um those
establishments in their Community also
um
the games of chance can be regulated
through zoning to specific zones and so
I believe that this uh is not necessary
because it can already be handled by
zoning and it's um just because it
wasn't handled by zoning in the case
that was brought before us does not mean
that it cannot be and that um there is
no need I think for this specific uh
allowance that they could essentially
regulate it through zoning even though
that is currently already allowed and so
I don't believe that this is either
timely uh it is um imper that it
happened right away since all all of the
testimony that we've heard is not going
and even the bill in front of us is not
going to affect any of the people even
in the pipeline not even for the people
that have proposed proposed uh uh sites
yet and so it's just not just not
necessary at this time and so um I hope
you will join me in not supporting this
amendment
representative Hicks thank you Mr
chairman my thought briefly is about
planning board uh when we went through
this and conquered we were only deciding
on the site plan we were not giving
approval to a casino so I think it would
be the planning board's role and that
would be limited to site
plan representative Gallagher um so just
to clarify this is amendment
218h that we're currently on that is
correct representative power thank you
Mr chairman as as noted this new
Amendment
1218 it um differs from the previous
Amendment 0
805h in that as the um we were it was
explained to us sections one and two
have been eliminated so that brings me
to um the question with regards to the
elimination of section two relative to
the local option of having historic
horse racing machines as I recall in the
hearing I did ask questions about this
likening um historic horse racing
machines to Kino and if I my
recollection is correct I was um we were
told during the hearing that historic
horse racing machines are not limited to
casinos and that they could those
machines could in fact be placed in say
like a gas station or Chinese restaurant
so if that is in fact um correct and
true I am confused as to
why the section two has been eliminated
because it seems to me like um that
would be an important section to retain
to allow for municipalities to have that
local option to weigh in yay or
nay thank you representa
FR thank you Mr chair um with all due
respect to representative power my
recollection from the hearing was that
gas stations and Chinese restaurants in
perhaps Texas do have the historic
racing machines but the way they are
defined here
they are in essence a subset of the
games of
chance and one would have to have a
casino license in order to install a
historic horse race machine in a gas
station Chinese restaurant what have you
uh perhaps some other members might
weigh in with their
Recollections representative kahill uh
thank you Mr chair yes I do believe that
representative fra is exactly correct
that that it's exactly how it was
explained to us in the hearing
um that's exactly
correct represent uh
power thank you Mr chairman um thank you
for filling in that Gap in my memory um
now that that's been stated because I
was focused on my municipality and Kino
and the Bingo now I do recall that yes
you have to have a a gaming license so
my follow-up question to that is do you
need a license for
Kino I'm I'm just I'm trying to
understand the issue
fully further
comments representative
Brown thank you Mr chairman so the other
night after our caucus I was concerned
about this bill trying to understand a
little bit more of the background so I
spent some time on Monday morning with
ol in regard to this and I wanted to
know how U the bill impacted uh
Littleton and how the bill uh could
potentially impact Conway and I also
spoke with representative Paige who was
a sponsor of the original bill so that
was clarified for me and and I guess um
kind of the basic summary of that is
people told me basically it's too late
for Littleton and it's too late for uh
Conway in regard to a bill of this type
and that uh Rochester for instance even
though they weren't operating uh they
were about to be able to start operating
so I understood what happened with the
original 15 and discussed with them
about where we would go forward with the
others that would be u in the future so
I I think several of the members
discussed uh the fact that um that
concerned that there's not a need for
this bill but based on the discussions
that I had with the uh on the sponsor of
the original bill and the background
that I got from OSS uh I feel that this
bill is indeed needed maybe not in this
exact format yet but the the idea was to
be proactive and making sure that the
towns
understood uh what the requirements were
uh to have these gaming operations in
their towns uh and that several of these
towns were surprised Ur rised by the
fact that they didn't have any control
over this um so in regard to this bill
being timed on I think it is because it
sets forth what the regulations would be
moving forward for additional uh gaming
operations thank
you representative K thank you Mr chair
I just kind of wanted to respond to
representative pow question about the
Kino um possibly maybe
we don't know the answer to that
question because this might belong in
another
committee with the knowledge of those
things further
comments okay uh just a couple I just
I'll recap what a a few items uh I sent
you all an email last night from uh Mr
Newman from the casino group um
basically saying that they had worked
with the sponsors and they were both in
agreement with this um July this would
become effective July one of this year I
know representative yella mentioned
moratorium I was on the assumption that
that was going to expire unless we had a
new yes it expires
um and the next um as been mentioned
Littleton um realizes that they won't
this won't apply to them it's a
unfortunately it's coming in late same
with Conway
way
um it would give the ability of other
municipalities in the future to um say
yay or
nay regulated through zoning I don't
believe that's the case uh as Littleton
found out and I believe um if uh what' I
say and Lebanon I'm I'm hearing
um that cannot be done um
let's
see I know it's been mentioned not today
but in other venues that this this is a
money issue and should be part of ways
and means I'll disagree with that
because this does not affect any current
um money coming in I know there's an
issue of you know if somebody doesn't
uh allow a casino wi they shouldn't uh
get percentage I don't disagree with
that but is that the case with Kino I
don't believe that's the case if a town
says no to Kino I believe they still get
it um the last thing I'll say
is I I go I go neutral kind of neutral
on this bill I can see the pluses and
the minuses I'll say the one big thing
is if a a mun municipality should have
the ability to say yay or nay to Kino I
think um games of of chance is a kind of
A step above that and I would think that
uh by using pretty much the same
language
um as The Kino language that this I
really don't see the downside in it
again I I I come out kind of agnostic on
this but those are the points I just
wanted to get get
through representative
yella um thank you um I wholeheartedly
disagree um with the argument that you
can't um regulate this by zoning just
because those municipalities chose to to
Define in their zoning
um
entertainment that and and entertainment
is a wide ranging um term that doesn't
mean that they couldn't use another term
that is more specific and Define it in
zoning as um you know games of Champs
they could literally call uh a section
games of Champs owned by by uh you know
uh and defined in their zoning and say
it's permitted in this area it has
conditional use in that area it needs
special exception in that area there's
nothing in statute that bars them from
doing that now and so um if there is I'm
happy to for you to show me that r a
however I do not believe that it exists
so I would just make that
comment uh represent K yeah I mean I
just this is just a question um I if if
because I I I tend to agree with
representative UK I mean my town has
adopted zoning ordinances Banning
certain things from coming to town that
you know some people would want um
so but why can't the why couldn't this
just be a simple amendment to put a
comma next to wherever in statute and it
talks about Kino and games of chance why
didn't we do something simple like
that representative
Brown thank you Mr chairman um so in my
time with OS the other day I U I was led
to believe as representative yis said
that uh it was possible to limit um
limit gaming through through the zoning
uh requirements that uh they would have
to be more specific than what was
initially indicated as far as uh
entertainment zones um I checked with
molten Boro um yesterday as well and
they did not have anything that would
prohibit that but I wasn't uh really
speaking to someone that was expert on
that in the town yes they weren't
available but I was led to believe that
that would be a possible solution
although I wouldn't quote that specific
but that's what I was led to believe the
other day thank
you further
comments okay seeing none uh we will
recess this um HP 1223 until 11 a.m. and
come back to that after our individual
coxes uh with that we'll go ahead and
open up the exact session on HB
1187 relative to prohibiting lease
agreements of equipment for building and
facility improvements and I believe
representative of power has an amendment
to introduce thank you Mr chairman I
would like to offer to the committee
Amendment
2024-25 n for your consideration do we
have a second on
that okay uh representative M McDonald
seconds and would you like to speak to
it thank you Mr chairman so um this uh
uh this uh Amendment
here
strike section two that um was discussed
and offered at the executive session
prior to when this bill was um pushed
until today so the the prior mment had
two sections the second section um had
these lease agreements as a special
warrant article that has been
removed and the minor change in the the
amendment before you section one Remains
the Same and that there was a um late
recommendation of the um inclusion of
three words and those words appear on
lines 15 and 16 and they are that become
fixtures so those three words modify
building or facility improvements that
become fixtures and that makes um it
very crystal clear that any accessory to
a piece of equipment may come under the
lease because they are non-permanent and
they are not fixed an example would be a
generator in the cabling required to
hook the generator up to the facility
the building so that type of accessory
parts to the main piece of equipment can
in fact be leased under this amendment
thank
you % of
Gallagher
um
so uh at least personally um okay so the
intent may have been by using
fixtures um to make things clear I don't
think it does actually make things
clearer though um I think that um
there's still some ambiguity about what
precisely fixtures means um you know uh
you off you can sometimes hear it used
in a metaphorical St um sense for
example of like oh the municipal
Association lobbyists are a fixture of
our committee for example um but
um
so yeah I I I appreciate the attempts to
try to improve the wording here but I'm
not sure if it's
successful uh representative power go
head now thank you Mr chairman and for
the sake of brevity I I I could talk
about this at length but I would like
the committee to be crystal clear that
the those three words came at the
recommendation of the New Hampshire
Municipal Association I was contacted um
late yesterday and um they recommended
upon further review I am quite certain
that the staff at the New Hampshire
Municipal Association is probably tired
of seeing amendments and drafts of this
particular bill so that being said this
has been um looked at by many
people and we are at the the wording
that is before us is is very precise and
correct it has been reviewed by
Municipal attorneys and I would further
note that the word fixtures is a legal
term and very well understand stood by
Municipal attorneys thank you
representative kill thank you Mr chair I
don't doubt that um fixtures is
understood by legal terms but what I
will speak to is a lifetime of someone
who has used tools and installed things
for his entire life and fixtures are
something that is permanently attached
and we don't want to be leasing
something that is permanently
attached if that's what you're using the
word to
representative major thank you Mr
chairman um having having spoken almost
daily with um with nhma about this
amendment I am confident that what we
have in front of us in
11129 uh comports with the law and would
be supported by nhma and I'll be
supporting the amendment thank you
representative power thank you Mr
chairman so regarding the um inclusion
of those three words in this amendment
if one would continue to read the
sentence it says building or facility
improvements that become fixtures
related to the installation purpose or
operation of such equipment shall not be
financed so I hope that clears things
up representative stavis just for
clarity sake we're looking at um 202
24-1
229h correct that's that's correct thank
you further comments questions
representative
lales just uh thank you Mr chairman U
just
a uh if I could pose a
question um a lot of communities now are
choosing to install solar panels on the
roofs of uh Municipal and School
District uh uh buildings
would they be
considered fixtures or would they be
able to be
least it's an excellent question
representative um see representative
Po's hand do you have an answer to that
thank you Mr chairman so um that would
be determined by the manner in which the
equipment is installed it has to do with
the the degree of the
installation a solar panel which can be
removed would be a piece of equipment
however it's my understanding that there
are Advanced um Technologies in which
the solar um technology is integrated
into the um Roofing uh material shingles
itself in that case um it would not that
that would that would be a fixed
item I hope that clarifies things and
and I will mention I think that's
exactly correct there's a different way
for panels to be either permanent or or
non-permanent I think that's correct
somebody else I saw no
okay seeing no more discussion I guess
we can uh call the role on the amendment
h not in this one do do you need
to okay okay very
good we can spend an hour on it if you'd
like representative
K all right uh when the clerk's ready
will call a roll on the
amendment okay adopt Amendment 1229 H uh
Vice chairman power yes representative
Guthrie clerk votes yes representative
lales yes
representative
Kella yes representative Kelly yes
representative award yes representative
Brown yes representative kahill yes
representative stavis yes representative
Tetro
yes represent Alin yes representative
Gilman yes representative majori yes and
representative Gallagher yes yes
representative Hicks yes representative
hland yes representative priest yes
representative Frack yes and Mr chairman
yes 20 to Zer the motion passes thank
you I assume no objections to the
consent
calendar well you have an objection
representative Gallagher or well we just
adopted the amendment so the Amendments
can't go on the consent calendar
anyway on the underlying bill have a
motion from representative power thank
you Mr chairman I move ought to pass on
House Bill
1187 with as Amendment as amended
representative PRI are you seconding
that I'm seconding it thank you
representative PRI seconds that motion
further
discussion once the clerk is
ready call a rooll on
the HB what was it uh 1187 1187 as
amended thank you uh Vice chairman power
yes representative Guthrie clect votes
yes representative sales yes
representative yella yes representative
Kelly yes representative awood yes
representative Brown yes representative
kill yes representative stavis yes
representative
Tetro yes representative elberger yes
representative yman yes representative
majority yes representative Gallagher
yes representative
yes representative howand yes
representative priest yes representative
Frack yes and Mr chairman
yes uh otpa passes 20 to Z thank you now
uh any objections to going on the
consent calendar seeing none it will go
on the consent calendar representative
power I assume you will write the
committee report very good correct all
right with that that closes the exec
session
on
1187 we've got two minutes and we can
open up the next
one
e
okay we're going to go ahead and open up
the exac session now on HB
1181 um just so everybody's clear there
are three amendments floating around on
this
one
and the gentleman from the Dr I believe
is here right did you want to Bri and I
will say briefly just explain that there
are three sections here we have
various uh
amendments one has one section one has
two sections one has three
sections
um sure we can do
that all right if we get to you we will
have you explain if we don't we won't
how's that okay so we've opened up the
exec s on HB 1181 and I believe
representative yella has a
motion um yes I have a motion to adopt
uh
04h is there a second on
that one
z48 H okay represent k k Hill
second they're they're all
pass
representative yo Kell now would you
like to speak to it sure I'm happy to um
so I believe that this is the simplest
of all the Amendments and I think it
gets really to the heart of what the
prime sponsor was trying to accomplish
which was that they were addressing the
the problem inside of the statute which
lists a bunch of things that they can do
um however um it specifically says that
they have the power to accept at a
district facility and in the cases where
um a large trash uh producer brings
something to their facility um it may
reach that facility's capacity and
create headaches for additional uh um uh
Solid Waste for that day or that time
period or however long it takes them to
actually um move that along in the
process so they wanted to be able to
direct um
people direct the solid waste generated
inside of the boundaries of their
District they didn't want to be able to
do that for the entire state but just
within the boundaries of their District
to their contracted third- party um
person that was is going to do the
processing of this and so I felt like
the uh this language was a little bit
more clear than the original proposed
language and um and then also kind of
sidestepped all of the complicated
issues in um in two and three um of the
bill so thank you fur the comments
representative uh major first thank you
Mr chairman um Mr chairman may I may I
read from what the prime sponsor of the
bill has sent over with regard to this
amendment you may you have the
thank you Mr chairman so um from the
prime sponsor of the bill representative
Vu um says the two sections that
representative yella that the
representative yella Amendment would
strike are the heart of the bill
allowing s Solid Waste districts to use
a manifest system like municipalities
and school districts would smooth out
the account payable process and ensure a
timely payment most Solid Waste
districts governing committees are
operated by volunteers often the only
reason the Committees meet is to approve
the payment of invoices if the committee
fails to get a quorum as often happens
in the summertime it may be weeks before
payment of invoices can be authorized
making payments overdue and in some
cases call finan cause financial
hardship for some of the vendors the
last change in the ellaa amendment in
extreme circumstances would allow Solid
Waste districts to appeal to the
Department of Revenue Services for
authorization to overspend their budgets
this option is only a last resort after
all other appeals have been exhausted
and is only possible and is only
possible if the district has a source of
funds already available as you can see
from the co-sponsor of the bill this is
non partis an issue it should be kept as
simple as a simple administrative
housekeeping Bill thank you Mr
chairman uh representative
power thank you Mr chairman um I'm I'm
in support of the section one of the
various amendments to this bill I know
we're speaking to um
1048 and I also concur with the um
comments feedback that the previous
representative had had shared um with
regards to the three sections and this
amendment before us has eliminated to
and I did also speak to the um Prime
sponsor as well as I contacted Mr canoer
from the Dr and had a very um
comprehensive discussion with him
yesterday he is here today to um fill in
any gaps and to
review um based on from the
hearing
um the way that the information was
presented I I missed a lot of key
details and I would um concur that the
heart of the bill is sections two and
three those sections are extremely
important to solid waste management
districts and that's not um we don't
have that in statute and unfortunately
it's not here in the bill in in front of
us oh I had and I had a question so if
we adopt this amendment here in front of
us we can uh replace it by adopting
subsequent amendments is that
correct you would be able to do that
yes further comments or
questions see uh representative
stavis I agree with what the previous
two speakers have said that this
amendment um eviscerates the bill and I
can't support
it for the
comments uh seeing that representative
power I'm inclined to um support this
amendment because it's a subset of
subsequent amendments so
um based on the the answer that if this
is adopted then other ones can replace
it I that's where I am right
now
oh hold on one
sec for the Comm uh representative
PRI I will also be opposing the
amendment uh 1048 H and I instead I will
be supporting the one that's being
sponsored by the no can't do that okay
thank you talking about this amendment
thank you representative Brown thank
thank you Mr chairman um I will not be
supporting this amendment although it is
part of my Amendment thank
you representative power thank you Mr
chairman so um my understanding has been
corrected and um I will not be
supporting this amendment due to the
clarification and the question that I
asked earlier thank you representative
yella thank you um I I think that that
is all wrong
that you can adopt an amendment and then
adopt a future Amendment they would have
to be merged and since all of the
Amendments actually include my language
the merging is there's no conflict
between the different Amendments of
adopting a further Amendment with
additional language um but it doesn't
really make any difference um uh in my
opinion whether we do it what if if some
people vote down the amendment and then
you know vote for a different Amendment
or not I think the result of the the
bill will probably end up being the
exact same no matter which way we move
forward further
comments give give me a couple minutes I
apologize my my head's still over the
North Atlantic today I'm not 100% so
hold on one
sec
e
I I believe the the first answer I gave
on adopting another amendment over
another amendment whether it's the first
one passes or fails I think is correct
and I think representative yella kind of
confirmed that I don't know why it
wouldn't um just sent something to the
clerk and we'll see if he answers here
pretty quickly but I believe that's the
case
okay according to the clerk once an
amendment is adopted in the exact
session I asked can another one
supersede that and the clerk said no
unless there's no
recommendation
so representative
power I I don't I having trouble
comprehending that answer could you
click clarify or or state it
differently I could not that's exact I
just read from here
that's basically it sounds once the
amendment is adopted that
becomes becomes the bill the bill unless
unless there's no recommendation or of
course it fails representative
Lala thank you Mr chairman even though
the yella amendment is duplicated
exactly in the brown
Amendment there is no guarantee that the
brown Amendment will
pass so if we pass the ukel
amendment and the brown Amendment failed
then the bill would be the ukel
amendment uh so my my thought is since I
want everything in the brown Amendment
I'm going to vote no on the ukel
amendment
and as I said pass the brown
Amendment okay we're going to take a
five minute recess and I'm going to
clarify this with the clerk because I'm
I want to make sure we do this right
so uh we will recess this till
BAS
so
there so
there they already have the ability to
do that through the
D
e
uh continue now on HB
1181 uh currently we have an
amendment allows them to do it see what
I'm saying I'm trying to okay that would
be my as soon as representative Brown
and majori cease their
conversation all right so here's the
deal I spoke with the clerk um we can
certainly do this amendment another one
can be introduced at the end depending
where we are they can U we would have to
merge them with OLS I don't didn't think
he understood that we have three parts
part one two and three and I would
assume
our U the way we'd go about it would be
number one number two and number three
so um right now we have under
discussion the amendment 1048 which is
uh the Oella Amendment Is there further
discussion on
that okay I see no others I'll I'll make
my comment um I'm I'm in favor of this
amendment I believe as we include more
and more I become less
um interested in this bill um but I for
this amendment I I do support further
comments seeing none we'll ask the clerk
to call a rooll on Amendment 1048 on HB
1181 thank you Mr chairman uh Vice
chairman power
yes Representative cby
no cler votes yes representative sales
yes representative Kella yes
representative Kelly
no representative award
yes representative Brown yes since the
chairman CL verified
it representative kahill
yes Representative stavis
no representative
Tetro
no that's a no just give me just a
minute here for a second representative
kahill that was a that was a yes yes I
was a yes okay thank
you and represent of T that was a no
that's affirmative thank
you
Jes represent
alberger
no representative Gilman no
Representative majori no representative
Gallagher no representative Hicks no
Representative howand no representative
priest
no representative Frank I vote
no Mr chairman
yes uh motion fails I believe 8 to 8 to
12 thank you further uh
amendments representative Brown do you
have an amendment yes I Mr chair Mr
chairman sorry um let me find it here
so Mr chairman I'd like to introduce
20241 1202
H do we have a second on
that representative lales seconds
that would you like to speak to your
Amendment representative
bar yes Mr chairman um I in doing this
after our caucus the other night uh felt
it was appropriate to include
representative was Amendment as well as
the to allow section two to be in this
bill I did not have section three in the
bill because I felt it uh was not needed
I felt that uh if the if the funds were
budgeted um and as I spoke with other
members that they could have a
contingency within that budget then they
did not need section three of the Bill
thank you
further comments representative
power thank you Mr chairman um I support
these two sections
um in this amendment and I'd like to
speak with regards to section two which
is the authority to pay debt so the
provisions under the section that it's
really it's very important to as the
prime sponsor um explained to me in a
conversation yesterday
that this is vital to the smaller mom
and pop
businesses for example he said that
provide hauling services for the Solid
Waste Management District and ontime
payments for these small businesses is
critical for them to maintain cash flow
and this proc and the Solid Waste
Management District they don't meet
regularly and my understanding is that
the one that's in my area the Sou heagan
um landfill District they don't meet
during the summer so this provision is
is vital and I would also um like to
explain that this process that's put
forward here by um members non-c
contemporaneously signing a manifest
that means that they are to go and
review the Manifest separately not at
the same time um and sign off enabling
the um Treasurer to be able to cut a
check to pay the bills this is the same
exact process that's allowed for school
boards and um select boards so I don't
really see a problem with this provi
provision and um additionally at every
meeting the Solid Waste Management
District Treasurer does in fact give a
report to the committee so um there is
um transparency and oversight with
regards to um this process and finally I
would add that solid waste management
districts are in fact audited um every
year according to the
Dr thank
you further
comments seeing none we will ask the
clerk to call the roll
on
hb1 U Amendment
122 uh Vice chairman power
yes representative Guthrie
no click votes yes representative as
silus
yes representative Kella
no representative Kelly
yes representative awood
yes representative Brown yes represent
thank you representative kahill
Representative stavis
no representative Tio
no Representative alberger no
representative Gilman no Representative
majori
no representative
Gallagher
no representative Hicks
no representative Howland
no representative Priest No
representative Frank no Mr chairman
yes motion fails 8 to
okay uh H 12 two Amendment fails
8-2 now we have the floor open for
another amendment representative
stavis thank you Mr chair I'd like to um
offer Amendment 2024
a-145
H amend HB 1181 and I think our positive
ways makes the bill stronger up up up up
we have a second representative majority
second
you like to speak to your Amendment
representative I think I just
[Laughter]
did are there further discussions
representative
power thank you Mr chairman so um in
preparation for this executive session I
did review the bill I did speak with the
prime sponsor and I also um took the
opportunity to reach out to Mr Bruce
canoer at the Dr he's the municipal
Bureau director and um as I stated
previously I had an extensive
conversation with him um I'm happy to
share um our discussion uh based on my
notes however Mr canoer is is here and
um if you would permit Mr chairman uh it
may be beneficial for him to speak to um
this um section three in particular I do
support this
generically I will say that um this is
the heart of the bill and um through our
conversation it was pointed out that why
this is so critical is there is a
technicality in statute where it's been
determined that with respect to a Solid
Waste Management District chapter 32
colon 2 Under the municipal budget act
that it does not apply and so so my
understanding and Mr canoer can can
clarify that due to that fact presently
there there is no procedure
um available for solid waste management
districts so that's why this is is so
important um to to have this and I'll
I'll leave it at that if you would allow
him to speak to section three in
particular
I hesitate is there anything you can add
do you believe or
is yeah we're not going to go through
and do the questions I um maybe
representative Prower can just give us a
an executive version of her conversation
with you I I think the committee has
pretty much kind of determined where
we're headed so anyway go ahead R so um
then then I'll do the best that I can
and
um so with regards to section three um
as I said that it's much needed due to a
technicality and statute um pertaining
to the municipal budget law particularly
32 col 2 application the issue at hand
is that it was originally thought that
the solid waste management districts um
would need to would fall this section
53 um would fall under the um Municipal
budget law application however a close
reading of that section and at the Dr
interpreted that this would not apply to
a
53-bp only and if you go and you read 32
colon 2 applic
a um again I will state I'm not going to
read the whole um section there but it
does say that
um it says including those created
pursuant to 53-a or
53-bp their budget at an annual meeting
of their voters so with regards to a
Solid Waste Management District there's
no annual meeting of Voters because
they it's comprised of the
committee
um so the other part that I would um
like to speak to is that this section
three again why it's so important is
that it establishes a clear procedure in
the event um of an overe expenditure or
an emergency that requires an
expenditure and importantly it provides
a mechanism for accountability
um my understanding through conversation
is that right
now they would just go about and and and
and and I guess seek the money
and importantly the source of Revenue
typically would be an unreserved fund
balance I think that's all I that I
have for that section thank
you representative
priest thank you Mr chairman I will be
supporting amendment 10
54h and I agree with all the statements
that have been made by the previous
representative thank you further
comments seeing none um I'll make mine
um I I will be against this section as I
mentioned before I
was for section one agnostic on two and
I'm dead set against three and for the
same reason I mentioned in the original
hearing and that is the use of the words
uh in line 21 of overe expenditures and
then at the end of it that line calling
using the word unusual circumstance I
think unusual circumstance is overly
broad um if it would have been emergency
expenditures and then utilizing some
sort of language in the main body of the
language of emergency I I would have
been for it but this is just just too
broad it opens up too much so I will not
support
this further
comments representative Brown just to
clarify Mr chairman the uh reason why I
object to section three is and and the
items in section four regarding the
contingency there's nothing that
prevents the uh the district from having
contingency funds to do this already
thank
you further comments represent
stavis yeah I would just say that there
is plenty of accountability worked into
this
amendment
um they cannot make these mer emergency
expenditures or ere expend while first
appealing to the governing bodies of the
member municipalities for a commensurate
adjustment the commissioner of Revenue
Administration has to accept an approve
any such
application um and the commissioner of
Revenue uh is free to disapprove any
expenditure unless the governing body
designates the source of Revenue to be
used so I just I I there's
accountability throughout this bill that
um I just don't see any holes in it
whatsoever I will support it further
comments seeing none when the clerk is
ready could we call the role
on Amendment
1054 h
okay our vice chairman in power
yes representative Guthrie
no click votes yes representative
lalis
yes representative Kella
no representative Kelly
no representative award
no representative Brown
no
no representative kahill uh please wait
till your name is called please now he's
got me all messed up here tell
you representative stavis yes
representative
Tetro
no representative
alberger yes representative Gilman yes
representative majori yes representative
Gallagher yes representative Hicks yes
representative Howland yes
representative priest yes representative
Frank yes Mr chairman
no um 12 to8 motion
passes
okay thank you Mr clerk uh
12-8 representative stavis I see your
hand up like to make a motion Mr
chair like to move um 1181 ought to pass
as
amended okay uh we second that
representative priest I see your hand up
down there sorry representative majority
he beat you to it okay so now we are
going
to vote on
hb1 181 as amended I assume it's a full
replacement so I probably no more
discussion or is there representative
Gallagher um
so
um actually never
mind thank you Miss uh representative
further
discussion representative priest I
believe that HB 1181 is very important
especially to the smaller towns in the
state and it's long overdue and I think
uh this bill provides guidance and
accountability and the means for them to
work with other communities to to
address their Solid Waste uh situations
thank
you thank you further comments
questions seeing none we'll ask the
clerk to call a role on 1181 as amended
by uh 105 1054
H ought to passes a
minute okay uh Vice chairman power
yes representative
Guthrie clerk votes yes representative
lales
yes representative yella
no representative Kelly
no representative award
no representative Brown
no
Representative
kahill no thank you sir repres stavis
yes representative Tetro
no representative alberger
yes representative Gilman yes
representative majori yes representative
Gallagher yes representative Hicks yes
representative Howland yes
representative priest yes represent
Frank yes Mr chairman no motion passes
12 to8 okay
otpa on 1181 does pass 12 to8 uh for the
majority report who am I going to have
for that representative stavis uh
representative Tetro could you turn off
your mic
please thank you um this will not go on
consent obviously uh representative
yella would you like to write the
minority um is the major minority uh
suggest going to be ought to pass with a
different amendment I would say yes okay
then then yes I'm happy to thank write
that representative power um thank you
Mr chairman um I'd like to
clarify the minority recommendation will
be written by representative yella and I
do believe that a specific Amendment um
needs to be to be specified that's fine
very good
if it's me I'm going to be suggesting
Amendment
104h
48h okay with that we'll close the exec
session on HB
1181 we
will we will take a uh a recess on exec
sessions we will come back on
1223 at why don't we make it right at
noon and in the meantime the Republicans
will caucus in here uh everybody else in
the room will have to vacate and find a
place to keep themselves for until noon
thank
you
e
on the other room over there says noon
so we're going to continue our
discussion now on uh the amendment 2024
1218 amending HB
1223 do we have any further discussion
on the bill representative
McDonald don't show that
see I told
you I'm only half a wa
um hold
on hold
on I have a
motion nobody put forth the amendment
yet on 1218 I thought we did
did oh yeah I did oh sorry about
that oh
okay
there all right I'll put forth the
sorry no we have not hb1 1218 uh
introduced by representative tarot
second and by representative majori is
that correct all right all right now for
the discussion that we've already
discussed on sorry about that
no
discussion representative Brown your
mic's on do you have something no okay
all right then we will call ask clerk to
call a rooll on Amendment
2024 1218 H representative power
no representative
Guthrie clerk votes no representative
lalis yes
representative Kella
no representative Kelly
yes representative award
no representative Brown
yes representative kill no no
okay representative stavis
yes representative Tetro yes
representative elberger yes
representative Gilman
yes representative majori yes
representative
Gallagher uh yes representative Hicks
yes representative Howland yes
representative priest
yes representative Frack yes and Mr
chairman
yes motion passes 15 to
five thank you Mr clerk do I have a
motion on for House Bill 1220
free
as represent
stavis thank you Mr chair I'd like to
move on to pass as amended on House Bill
1223 we have a
second second second
David representative priest
seconds okay further comments anybody
want to
speak on
this I will represent K yeah I'll be um
I'm gonna be voting voting no on the
bill I I just personally believe that
this bill should have been seen by by
another committee and I just want that
on the on the record thank you
representative State uh power thank you
Mr chairman um this was a very difficult
um bill for me and a vote while I
um would support the notion of an
enabling legislation for municipalities
to be able to make this um particular
decision my concern is that Municipal
and County government while this is
enabling statute and that's we are
familiar with that um in terms of um
gambling games of chance this is not
these types of bills don't come to this
committee therefore I don't feel that we
are properly equipped to make the best
decision with regarding with regards to
this bill and in fact it should have
gone to a different committee because to
the best of my knowledge this is my
second term such um bills with regards
to games of chance like I said don't
come here so I'm very uncomfortable um
and I I I just lack the the bigger
picture as to how this fits in and the
different parts and pieces to um
currently what's in statute and what
different bills that have passed so um
it's very difficult but I will um I
would like to see this perhaps filed
again um next year and um it go to the
proper committee thank
you rep representative
yella yes thank you um one thing that I
had not previously mentioned in the
committee is that we're changing the
default status of
um allowability of these um
establishments from um from allowed to
not allowed unless specifically stated
we're also um specic uh and that is also
changing not only slot machines it's
changing um the uh card games or any
other like the charity ones all of them
would have to be specifically allowed
first before they would be able to
continue
their um uh operations after this
uh goes into effect and so um it's we
didn't have any any people you know
testifying about that fact and there is
just you know a myriad of issues that
have not been fully vetted out by this
rushed process uh and so for that reason
among others um I urge you to vote
against this representative
priest uh thank you Mr chairman I will
be supporting the UT to pass the motion
as amended
because gambling is now legals since
2021 and I think anything that the local
communities can do to prevent it from
going into their boundaries is in this
bill and I think that should be given a
priority thank you forther
comments representative
majori thank you Mr chairman and given
that the moratorium is is going to be
expiring here giving uh municipalities
the chance to say yes or no giving them
the voice in that discussion giving them
that ability to make that decision that
is best for them uh gives me reason to
vote in favor of this bill although I do
want to say yeah I don't either I I
agree I don't like that this came to us
because this ain't us but given that we
have it and we seem to we have a
timeline I can uh after doing some
homework and speaking with people
certainly support the bill as amended
thank
you uh representative yell yeah I just
wanted to respond to the claim that
gambling was allowed in 2021 it was
allowed
in the state far before
2021 um I think you're referencing
specifically horse horse uh the horse
racing um Bill and that is not what is
covered by this bill this is far more
and uh and has been longstanding you
know the the card rooms throughout the
state all of those things gambling has
been allowed you know for for much
longer than that and this seeks to
change that long longstanding um uh
situation uh in relationship between the
law and and municipalities that has been
um existing for uh a long time and doing
it in a h halfhazard way is
inappropriate thank you representative
Gilman thank you Mr chair um I just like
to follow up on a couple of uh comments
that were made um I uh agree that
another committee should have heard this
um maybe us and another committee um
because this is talking about because
it's proposing a local option that's a
local government and that's municipal
government uh and so that is why part of
why I think we saw this um and I had
another point which is not oh and we
have seen um historic horse racing and
and uh charitable gaming bills here
before so
thank you further comments
questions um I'll make a quick comment
we've heard several uh speakers talk
about whether it came to our committee I
would totally agree with representative
Gilman's last comment about it is a
municipal and County uh issue in some
respects I will also say state that in
order for this to have come to the this
committee it required the approval of
the speaker of the house which I did
receive
um the other issue
is we needed a bill that was not going
forward to do a complete replacement on
and that was hp1
1223 people probably don't remember but
the the uh sponsor didn't show so this
was a bill that was going to get killed
so this was a vehicle to allow this bill
to go forward um the other uh comment
I'll make is
um if and when it passes out of this
committee this is the first hurdle a lot
more many more hurdles this is going to
have to go through it's going to go
first through the house floor then it's
going to go over to the senate committee
and it's going to go to the full
Senate if it makes it pass all that then
you have the governor who still needs to
sign it so this is even if it comes out
of this committee with an OTP a is no
guarantee at all that this is going to
make its way to the end so just want to
keep you on that representative
don't I just got a general question when
will the bill title
change uh I I don't know I'd have to go
back and look at
that
yeah it's line three or further
comments or
questions seeing none uh when the clerk
is ready we'll call the vote on HB 1223
as amended by TW H um Amendment 1218 H
otpa thank you Mr chairman uh Vice
chairman power no representative
Guthrie clict votes no no representative
silus yes representative yella
no representative Kelly yes
Representative aood
no representative Brown yes
Representative kahill
no representative stavis yes
representative Tetro yes representative
alberger yes representative Gilman yes
representative majori yes representative
Gallagher yes representative Hicks yes
representative Howland yes
representative priest yes representative
Frack yes and Mr chairman
yes motions and passes 15 to5 thank you
Mr clerk uh this will go on the regular
calendar uh the majority report will be
written and as represent stavis will you
be writing
that thank you representative stavis
will write the majority report
representative yella has already sent me
The Minority
Report thank you all right so that
closes the exec session on that bill now
before anybody leaves anybody who has a
committee report don't leave this room
until you've got it to me because we
have to have those in shortly otherwise
they don't make the calendar okay so I
need those
immediately um beyond
that that wraps up all our bills for the
session other than Of course house
action but yeah so we are done whatever
we had 52
bills well done thank you everybody and
uh we will see you
tomorrow
e